de la halle du marché de maurepas n'y
reste que la structure le feu a
totalement détruit ce lieu
incontournable de la commune
depuis des travaux du fourrage ont été
effectués pour sécuriser les lieux
suite à un incendie le rendez-vous du
marché s'est tout de même maintenu cet
été au square de la marche
un emplacement provisoire que les
commerçants n'ont pas vraiment apprécié
qu'il a fallu faire avec les moyens du
bord quelque part de d'installer
sommairement les commerçants avec
quelques petites problématiques liées à
l'électricité liées à l'emplacement où
il ya le soleil par exemple
depuis ce week end le marché de maurepas
se tient désormais à côté de la halle
sur la place riboud ce qui facilite les
conditions de travail des commerçants un
nouveau rendez vous que les riverains
n'ont pas manqué c'est une solution
d'attentes mais ça fait plaisir ça fait
plaisir de voir que avec la saison qui
reprend bas notre marché reprend vie
aussi voilà donc c'est une bonne chose
j'ai trouvé que c'était bien et puis
j'espère qu'on va les protéger un petit
peu pour l'hiver voilà c'est tout mais
c'est bien ici on sent un peu tassé on
voudra va chercher un peu mais c'est pas
grave
avec l'arrivée des mauvais jours une
tante va être installé pour garder le
lieu au sec
concernant la reconstruction de la halle
une grande concertation va être lancée
par la municipalité cet automne l'idée
c'est de recueillir leurs opinions leurs
idées et je l'écris dans une lettre
récemment
est-ce qu'on leur on doit reconstruire à
l'identique est ce qu'on doit aussi
s'inspirer de ce qui se fait ailleurs
la réouverture de la halle du marché de
maurepas devrait se faire d'ici deux ans